In the last video, we
did problem 65,
and we got the answer.
And we did it in kind of an
intuitive way, but if it was a
slightly harder problem, it
would've gotten a little more
complicated, so I really wanted
to show you how you can
do it with the binomial theorem
as well, or at least
with binomial coefficients, and
then we can try to see how
they relate to each other,
that they're
actually the same thing.
I realized that I should do
this, because I'm looking at
the next couple of questions,
and they all deal with the
binomial coefficient.
So I figured I might as well do
it the binomial way because
that's probably what
the California
Standards want you to do.
And it's a good way.
It's good to be able to do it
intuitively and with the
binomial coefficients and
understand how they're the
same thing.
So reading the same problem,
Teresa and Julia are among 10
students who have applied
for a trip to D.C.
Two students from the group
will be selected at
random for the trip.
What is probability that Teresa
and Julia will be the
two students selected?
So the way we did it last time,
we said, OK, we could
pick Julia first, and there's a
1 in 10 chance, and then we
would pick Teresa, and that's
a 1 in 9 chance.
Or we could go the other way
around, so it would be 2 times
1/10 times 1/9.
2, because there's two different
ways to pick the
people, and then for each of
those ways, there's a 1 in 10
chance of picking the first
person and then a 1 in 9 for
the second.
That was the intuitive way we
did that in the last video.
The way you would do it with
the binomial coefficient is
you'd say, OK, I have 10 items,
10 students in this
case, and I'm going to
choose two of them.
And people will often read
this as 10 choose 2.
And it's useful to memorize to
some degree what this means.
This means 10 factorial
over 2 factorial
times 10 minus 2 factorial.
And so that is equal to-- and
I'll give you in a second what
the intuition is.
That's equal to 10
factorial over 2
factorial times 8 factorial.
And at first, you might say, oh,
my God, 10 factorial is a
huge number.
It's going to take me forever
to multiply that out, until
you realize that you're dividing
it by 8 factorial.
So 10 factorial, that's the same
thing as 10 times 9 times
8 times 7, and you keep going.
But 8 factorial is 8 times
7 times 6 and so
forth and so on.
So the 8 factorial, if you
divide into 10 factorial,
that's going to cancel
out with that.
And you're just left
with 10 times 9.
So if you have to say, how many
different ways can you
pick 2 people out of 10?
You then get 10 times 9, which
is 90, divided by 2 factorial,
which is 2 times 1, so you say
there's 45 different ways to
pick 2 people.
So the chances that I pick one
of those ways, pick Julia and
Teresa, is 1 out of 45.
There are 45 combinations of
picking 2 people out of 10.
So the chances of picking
any one of those
combinations is 1 out of 45.
So you get to the same answer.
And just to get the intuition,
this thing boils down
to-- we just saw.
It boils down to 10 times
9 over 2 factorial.
And if you just want the
intuition, there's 10 ways to
pick the first person, there's
9 ways to pick the second
person, and then there's 2 ways,
or 2 factorial ways,
that you could have picked
one person and
then another person.
So it's the same intuition
as this.
But if you just wanted to kind
of plug and chug and get the
answer, you say, oh,
10 choose 2.
That gives me the answer.
I have 10 things.
I need to choose 2.
That gives me 45 different
combinations and I want only
one of them.
So that's 1 out of 45.
Next question.
Let me see.
Scroll up.
All right.
And when I saw this, I said, oh,
they definitely want us to
deal with binomial
coefficients.
And I'll show you two ways how
to do this problem, too.
So this one says 3y minus
1 to the fourth power.
And you can multiply it out just
using regular algebraic
multiplication, polynomial
multiplication.
It will take you some
time and you might
make a careless mistake.
I'm guessing they want us to
use the binomial theorem.
And the binomial expansion
of this-- I'll use that
combinatorics or that binomial
coefficient notation.
I think you'll get
the pattern.
And I've done several videos on
this where I explain deeper
why it works and all of that.
But it equals 4 choose 0 times
the first term to the fourth
power, 3y to the fourth, times
the second term to the 0th
power, so you don't
include it.
That's times 1.
Anything to the 0th power is 1.
Fine.
Plus 4 choose 1 times the first
term, so that's 3y to
the third power-- I'm just
decrementing it on each term--
Times the second term to the
first power, so times negative
1 to the first power.
And, in general, if you want
to know what should this
exponent be, it's going to
be whatever is here.
So this one is the
same as that.
So here we had a 0, so negative
1 to the 0, I didn't
even take the trouble
to write that down.
Let me just keep going.
I'll switch colors.
So the next term, you could
probably pause it and guess
it, is going to be 4 choose 2.
And I know you're wondering
well, what is this 4 choose 1
and 4 choose 2?
Well, we saw it in the last
problem, but I'll calculate
them in a second.
That's going to be 3y squared
times negative 1 squared.
And we have two more terms.
Plus 4 choose 3
times 3y to the 1.
And just so you know, the
exponents of these two should
always add up to 4.
So you have 4 and 0, you
have 3 and 1, 2 and 2.
So in this case, you have
times negative 1 to the
third-- and this 3 is that 3--
plus 4 choose 4 times negative
1 to the fourth power.
So what do each of these
binomial coefficients equal?
4 choose 0, that is equal to--
I'll do it in yellow.
That's equal to 4 factorial over
0 factorial, which, you
may or may not know, is defined
to be 1, over 0
factorial divided by 4
minus 0 factorial.
And so that just turns
into 1, right?
4 minus 0 is 4.
So you get 4 factorial
over factorial.
So this is equal to 1.
So let me write it out.
So 3y the fourth.
3 to the fourth power is what?
It's 81.
So we get 81 y to the fourth.
All right.
Next term.
Well, the first thing that you
see is you have this negative
1 to the first power.
This negative 1 is just going
to keep flipping the sign.
So negative 1 to the first
power, that's just going to
make this whole term negative
and then we can
ignore it from there.
So we're going to get a negative
there because of this
negative 1 to the first power.
And what's 4 choose 1?
So that's 4 factorial over 1
factorial, which is also 1,
divided by 4 minus
1 factorial.
So that's 4 factorial
over 3 factorial.
So it's 4 times 3 times
2 times 1 divided by 3
times 2 times 1.
So that just equals 4.
Try it out if you don't
believe me.
4 times 3 times 2 times 1
divided by 3 times 2 times 1,
you're just left with a 4.
So you get 4.
This coefficient becomes 4.
But it's 4 times 3 to
the third power.
So maybe I'll just write it.
The binomial coefficient is
4 times 27y to the third.
And we already took care
of the negative 1.
Negative 1 to the first
power is negative 1.
And that's why I put
the negative there.
So the next term.
We have a negative 1 to the
second power, so it's going to
be a positive.
This is going to
turn into a 1.
That turns into a 1.
So it's plus-- what's
4 choose 2?
4 choose 2 is-- I'm already
running out of space.
I'll write it up here.
It's 4 factorial over
2 factorial
times 4 minus 2 factorial.
4 minus 2 factorial, that's
also 2 factorial.
So it's equal to 4 times 3 times
2 times 1 divided by 2
factorial is 2 and
2 factorial is 2.
Let's say this 2 cancels
out with that 2.
This 2 cancels-- let's see, if
you cancel out that 2, that
becomes a 2.
So you get 2 times 3
just becomes a 6.
So that third term
4 choose 2 is 6.
I know this is messy.
So you have a plus 6
times 3y squared.
So 9 times 9y squared.
And we could go keep going.
And actually, the binomial
coefficient, the next one's
going to be a 4, and it's
negative 1 to the third, so
it's going to be a minus
4 times 3y to the 1.
I mean, we could keep going.
Actually, let's just
keep going.
So the next term, 4 choose 3,
I'll leave that for you to
calculate it, but I already know
that since we're kind of
past the middle point, the
binomial coefficient is going
to be the same as 4 choose 1.
So it's going to be a 4 and we
have a minus 1 to the third,
so this is minus 1.
So it's minus 4 times 3y
to the 1, so times 3y.
And then we have
the last term.
4 choose 4-- you could calculate
it using this
formula, but that turns out to
be 1 as well-- plus 1 times
negative 1 to the fourth,
so that's just plus 1.
And let's see what
this is equal to.
Let's see if we can
simplify it.
This is equal to 81y to the
fourth minus-- let's see, 4
times 20 is 80, 4 times
7 is 28, so it'd be
108, 108y to the third.
6 times 9 is 54, so
plus 54y squared.
Minus 12y plus 1.
And if we look at the choices,
only choice A
is the right answer.
And actually, we could have
figured out it was choice A
just by going one term deep,
because that's where all of
the choices- became different,
so we could have
saved a lot of work.
Another option: Instead of
evaluating each of the
binomial coefficients, another
option would have been to do a
Pascal's triangle, where you
say, OK, if I have a plus b to
the first power, the
coefficients are 1 and 1,
right, 1a plus 1b.
If I take it to the second
power, a plus b squared, the
coefficients become
1 plus 1 is 2.
You bring down a
1 both places.
And that makes sense because a
plus b squared is 1a squared
plus 2ab plus 1b squared.
And then we could
have kept going.
This would have been
to the third power.
You had a 1, a 3, a 3 and a 1.
And then the fourth power is
what this problem was about.
So you get a 1, you get a 4.
3 plus 3 is 6.
3 plus 1 is 4, and
you get a 1.
And so these would be the
coefficients, and in this
case, we were doing 3y minus
1 to the fourth power.
If we had just drawn this out
really fast, we would have
said, well, this becomes 1 times
3y to the fourth plus 4
times 3y to the third-- I just
keep decrementing the 3y--
times negative 1 to the 1 plus
6 times 3y squared--
this 6 is this one.
I'm getting a little
misaligned-- 3y squared times
negative 1 squared.
So every time I increment the
power on negative 1 and I
decrement the power on 3y.
And then plus 4.
Now I'm at this one.
Plus 4 times 3y negative
1 to the third.
And then finally plus 1 times
3y to the 0 is just 1 times
negative 1 to the the
fourth power.
And I would have evaluated it.
And that might have been
a slightly faster
way of doing it.
But I wanted to do this a
couple of different ways
because I think the binomial
theorem and binomial expansion
is something that people forget,
and it's important to
kind of have the neurons make a
lot of cross-connections so
that you don't forget it when
you're 30 years old.
Anyway, this was the least
number of problems I've done
in a video, but I think
it was worth it.
I'll see you in the
next video.